[Music]
[Applause]
he was a champion at
ucla and of course five-time all-star
he's also a great actor which we'll get
into that coming up in a moment he's
marcus johnson the bucks tv
analyst for fox sports milwaukee marcus
thanks for joining us
um what did you think last night when
you saw the greek freak go up to contest
clint capela
well good morning dan first of all um
you know it it it reminded me of a of an
injury that i had when i played with the
bucks i got
kicked trying to contest a jump shot
by a player by the name of paul thompson
of the cleveland cavaliers in the early
80s and my knee
hyper extended back like that got locked
it was most painful
injury that i've ever had as a
basketball player but i went to the
locker room
jeff snedeker our great trainer in
milwaukee at the time worked on it a bit
and i actually returned in the second
half and don nelson told me thought i
was going to be out for the year based
on the
on the reaction that i had and so to see
honest kind of loosen it up a little bit
walk on his own was
was promising but um you know everybody
uh started texting me right away and
it's kind of like why
does this always kind of happen to us
why can't we never have good things in
milwaukee
happen to us but you know we got to wait
to see what happens i'm hopeful that um
you know if we can extend this thing to
a seventh game maybe he can get back if
not
you know we'll see we'll see what the
mri says today i don't want to get ahead
of myself but
i'm not ruling him out right now until i
hear definitively that
he's got some kind of a tear or
something that's going to prevent him
from playing
and it might come down to the supporting
cast for the box against the supporting
cast for the atlanta hawks and if that's
the case
who has the advantage man that's a tough
one
uh because of this dan and and let me
preface this by saying that i'm just
really
impressed with the job that these
african-american coaches are doing in
the playoffs between ty lue and monty
williams and
and then my guide nate mcmillan i was
with him in seattle
uh you may recall with george carl and
the sonics
in the mid mid 90s ice always compare
him to sidney poitier and call him mr
tibbs because he's got that quiet kind
of elegance and dignity
but but they call me mrs tibbs but yeah
yeah yeah but
but but nate you know this whole thing
but connected like a fist and you know
the calming influence
i think is a big key for them but but
more tangibly
uh bogdanovic the knee speaking of knees
the knee is looking better he looked
really good
really mobile especially uh his activity
on defense heard her
a kayvon or whatever they call it him
has been a real
a real revelation i've always liked it
but now he's kind of
taking his taking that step to the next
level uh
and you go along with the other guys who
are playing exceptional basketball for
them
and then cam reddish it's funny cam
radish i was talking to my son chris
and he's like cam reddish is the guy
like like uh the
he's the guy that all the young players
kind of look up to
and anthony edwards says that cam
reddish is that dude you know
i didn't know that i know cam reddish
had that kind of reputation kind of
coming up in the aau ranks
he looked good last night so we've got
enough chris middleton
and and here's the other point i don't
want to get too long-winded but you got
a lot of guys
kendrick perkins stephen jackson talking
about chris middleton is the batman
and giannis is the robin now chris is
our closer because he can shoot
and shoot with the best of them down the
stretch now we'll get a chance to see
uh just uh how truthful of of an
observation
like that is and that's not to put the
the pressure on chris because he
he did a great job when chris when uh
giannis went down against miami last
year
he's done a great job this year when
he's had to carry the load we saw what
he could do
the game before last with the 20 point
fourth quarter but but chris is the kind
of guy
that can under certain circumstances
carry you but
giannis takes so much pressure off of
him because of the gravity
he creates and so it's a symbiotic type
of relationship between the two
so we'll see we'll see how it pans out
we got enough to do it uh the question
is mentally
uh will we be able to to to kind of
uh quell this hawk juggernaut
this momentum they built this last ball
game so we'll see it'll it'll be it'll
be
fascinating to see how it plays out
either way you start to look at players
in today's generation and i know you and
i would go i remember back in the
70s or 80s and guys would play and they
would have
you know injuries like there's load
management here but these guys are in
the best shape
they got nutrition they got trainers
they got private travel
so i'm trying to figure out is it just a
coincidence that we have these injuries
here if if i have load management then
should we be having as many injuries as
we have and there's some some you can't
prevent
but i didn't think that anthony davis
was in shape
i didn't think that james harden was in
shape this year
and you got load management so what is
the difference
in generations you know with these guys
and how they prepare and how you did you
know back in the 70s or 80s
well it's interesting because we worked
harder
like myself for example guys used to
hate to work out with me because i work
really hard especially
i mean leap frogs with 25 pound weights
behind my back
so now i'm paying the price so now i've
got i've got all kinds of disc
issues and hip issues and everything you
know i was talking to giannis
probably two years ago and i asked him
about his off-season
workouts i mean how much he ran and did
he run beaches and hills and
he's like no no i just do a lot of
defensive slides and i play a lot of
basketball
and so it lifts a lot of weights and
does a lot of cardio stuff in terms of
machines and equipment and that's that
type of stuff too
but it's a different approach but also
dan i mean this was the quickest
turnaround you know all this stuff quick
quickest turnaround in professional
sports history
from when the bubble season ended to
when this season started
uh the the condensed scheduling of the
72 games was as condensed
as it's ever been they're playing every
other day i mean
you know these guys just their bodies
aren't used to that
uh kind of taxation on their skeletal
system if you will
and so i think a lot of that had to do
with that
and so it's but my point is that it's a
give and take so yeah
i worked out hard did a lot of
unconventional crazy stuff leaper
machines and all this other crazy stuff
we had back in the day
but i'm paying the price for it now
these guys will probably not have
as many post-career issues but
this game of basketball you're out there
40 minutes a game
playoff intensity doing the things that
you're doing
i've always believed a case in point
with giannis and chris middleton
when coach budd first got to milwaukee
they were playing just
over 30 minutes a game yeah my point was
that when the playoffs get here man
you're going to be playing 40 minutes a
game and so our people were like we've
got other ways to compensate for that
without putting a lot of pressure in the
schedule system and my thing
has always been man you got to get out
there and play you can't
you can't manufacture anything that
replicates playing on that hardwood
jumping landing coming up and down it's
not the jumping that gets you somebody
told me
it's like the landing the constant
landing and the pounding
and so um it's just a different approach
nowadays and i think you're seeing
some of the fault out from the quick
turnaround that was necessitated
obviously by the
by the league needing to play a certain
number of games to
to get paid so everybody wants to get
paid so it was necessary he's marcus
johnson the bucks tv analyst for fox
sports milwaukee five-time
nba all-star yeah you start to wonder
you know look at lebron he's got three
extra
seasons of playoff basketball in that
body which
to do what he does and still be able to
do that
i mean that's that's freakish that's
that's crazy i mean it's not like
kareem or wilt or some of these other
players like lebron is
bringing the ball up the floor like he's
you know
it's a little bit different what we ask
of lebron than we do
probably any other player in nba history
to be able to do it this long this well
and uh he continues to do it what do you
think of lebron
i love lebron i'm uh my family between
myself my sons chris josiah
who's uh the king of nba twitter right
now but uh
no we we're we're big lebron fans
and it's mainly because of a few things
i mean
just in terms of no scandal
no you know i mean some comments on some
some issues or whatever that you could
call it a question
but in terms of how he has conducted
himself how he's giving back to his
community
the school that he building accurate all
that i mean that's great stuff but more
tangibly
what is he 15 16 years in and he's still
playing at an
mvp level still
and and so i talked to coach wooden uh
interviewed coach wood myself chris and
josiah
uh for for a piece i was doing um about
coach wooden
and we asked him about lebron and kobe
and this is gonna get a lot of people
upset a lot of kobe fans in los angeles
in particular
but he felt like lebron was more of his
kind of a player because he was a past
first team guy and uh was not looking to
bring a lot of attention to himself that
that's not
absolutely true but but but i've always
been a big lebron fan
and the fact that he's 15 16 years in 36
years old whatever it is
the way he takes care of himself uh just
just the uh
persona that he exudes whether you like
him or not in terms of
some of the stances that he takes he's
taking stances he's taking stances
and he's out there producing and even
more tangibly as a basketball player
he controls the game as well as anybody
i've seen
since magic johnson with the ball in his
hands and so to me that's uh
that's saying that saying something
magic's one of my all-time favorite
uh guys i played against and guys that i
like to watch play
i mentioned that uh you got quite a
resume of uh acting credits here
you have you have a scene in one of my
it's it's
i don't like the movie per se because i
didn't think they were believable as
basketball players
but i loved your scene and white men
can't jump like i think i could take
wesley snipe
right now in hoops one on one uh
woody looks like he had a little bit of
game there marcus
but tell me how you got the role when
white men can't jump
well we did a we did a uh film for a
student film project for the american
film institute up in the hills of
pasadena late at night
myself and nigel miguel and silk kozar
and all these actors
it was based on the life of raymond
lewis this great l.a
legend just myth in terms of a
basketball player
and so um silk cozart was good friends
with ron shelton who wrote them who
wrote the movie
and they were casting for the part and
so still got me the audition now i
they sent me the the sides the the
dialogue i had to use to read
with wesley snipes and i saw that there
was a scene where my character
pulled out a knife on wesley snipes
and so i'd seen a scene from a movie
where this uh
protagonist uses a razor blade
uh straight razor and so my dad was a
barber i wouldn't got one of his razors
and practice kind of open it up and
with one hand and so when he got to that
part of the scene with wesley
i did the whole thing and chased him
around the audition room and
and so ron shelton was like man that's
great great that's great you got the
part
but believe that leave that freaking
blade at home next time we got problems
with that stuff
you're gonna kill somebody with that
thing and so so i got the part like that
but uh but the other thing dan that's
interesting is that that that character
is based on a real life guy by the name
of reggie harding i wrote a screenplay
just finished it a couple of months ago
but just the the research
was fascinating he was one of the first
high school to pro guys to detroit
out of detroit early 60s but but i
talked to dave bing and ray scott the
coach of the year with the piston was a
teammate of his
but but reggie was challenging wilt
chamberlain you're not the big man
i'm the big man i'm gonna kick your
behind this is during the course of a
game and so uh
so but but it's just fascinating that
that that led me to
doing some research on who this
character really was he was he was
heroin addicted he got shot and killed
on the streets of detroit
at 30 years old he just crossed paths
with satchel paige
goose tatum so many so many characters
and so many great uh
historical figures in in sports so uh
and he comes into a convenience store
he's seven
feet tall exactly and and you know they
go
uh reggie and then he makes it seem like
no that's not me
and that's that's what your scene is
that's i see and that's the first thing
one of the first
first stories you would hear as an nba
player was that story but reggie harding
and true life had robbed that same
store like five or six times you know he
was robbing
drug houses over and over again to get
money you know and he go in with this
mask on at seven feet tall
like come on reggie he's like this ain't
me this ain't me so that's that's the
name of the supreme play this ain't me
uh but but uh yeah it's a tragic tragic
ending but
i had a lot of fun doing a movie and uh
work with a lot of great people and
you're right
woody so woody and i quick story first
time we played together uh pick up
basketball that just wanted us all to
play at the at the hollywood uh
hollywood rec center and so what he
called this bogus foul dan so i'm like
come on woody that was a bullcrap vow so
whitney's like
what do you mean what do you mean why
would you impugn my integrity why would
you impute my integrity
i like woody first of all first of all i
went to crenshaw i have no idea
number two it was still a bullcrap fire
just laughed and we
kind of bonded after that but we got a
ball man we had a ball doing that
i talked to rosie perez recently and she
said
she went out to lunch with wesley snipes
and woody harrelson
and she said they got stoned and and she
said then they came back
and uh you know ron shelton wanted to
make you know you guys were getting
ready to shoot
she said they were stoned and i don't
know how they were able to act but they
were stoned on i said
were you and she goes no i i couldn't i
i couldn't i would have been so paranoid
but she said those guys were stoned
through most of the movie
well woody had had the uh the wrap party
the big cass
rap party at his his uh career out in
malibu
where he had the big tp in the backyard
a real
regulation size official indian tp of
course native american tv excuse me my
wife's native american i gotta
be careful about that but but but he had
the native american tp
and in the tp man you go in there you're
not coming out the same person
you're coming out a whole different dude
when you after you leave out of that tv
so yeah but we had a great time
woody had some good stuff
the best uh hey great to talk to you as
always hope you're well
and the family and uh thanks for thanks
for getting up early with us
always a pleasure man thank you that's
marcus johnson white men can't jump he
was in blue chips
but he was in a lot of tv shows uh l.a
law
boston legal hanging with mr cooper
he was also a wonderful player at ucla
smooth
smooth player number 54.